Murray Singh director of the central
aquarium turned sustainable fish farm
operator located in the castle sediment
Murray is not only a pivotal member of
our community she is Manny's baby mama
if you remember what he was like when he
lost his toys all those months ago
imagine if something happened to Murray
agents get her back
be careful though our drones have been
picking up some weird signals in the
area but any Movement we seem to locate
has been clouded by some sort of Blue
Smoke
thank you
Murray Singh is the director of the
Washington DC Aquarium when animal
rights groups protested the inhumane
captivity of the aquarium's Dolphins
they cited it as animal cruelty and from
here there began a number of long drawn
out lawsuits filed against the aquarium
with the impact of these lawsuits and
the outcry from the public the aquarium
started to lose Revenue at an alarming
pace
unable to afford hiring a spokesperson
the responsibility fell solely on
Murray's shoulders to be the voice and
face of the organization they soon
realized that keeping the Dolphins at
the aquarium was no longer a feasible
and ethical option for them and
immediately began focusing the efforts
and funds on rehoming the memos to a
local sanctuary as releasing them back
into the wild was not a possibility
some of these animals had spent the
entirety of their lives at the aquarium
and others had been captured when they
were so young their captivity was the
only life they really knew
although devastating to say goodbye to
these Dolphins as the aquarium staff had
built such close bonds with them over
the years ultimately they had to put the
animal's well-being Above All Else and
so even with such great financial cost
to the aquarium along with the financial
strain from the lawsuits Murray made the
hard decision to re-home them
of course this was the plan before the
dollar flew outbreak caused the whole
city to be put into lockdown
Murray embodies weariness
professionalism in a practical approach
potentially to a fault
she understands that certain things need
to be done in order to achieve
objectives
following the division's successful
Rescue of the aquarium community and
agent Kelso's absence in New York Murray
enters a relationship with many
upon Kelso's return many discovers
Mary's pregnancy which revitalizes his
commitment to restoring the Castle's
settlement and transforming it into a
secure Sanctuary for their expanding
family
thank you for dinner
oh I told you I owed you one
it's been a really long time since I've
had a meal this good
I'm glad you enjoyed it
thank you for the Easy Company well when
you invited me over for fish tacos I
wasn't sure if it was some kind of code
you know for um
and uh never mind
I have kind of an awkward question okay
what's the deal with you and Kelso it's
a deal are you two together oh God no no
that's no no she's beautiful but not my
type too chaotic and Young
good to know
would you like a drink I got some wine
from the theater settlement treated
three fish for it they say it's quote
the good stuff
I'm gonna need to jump in here and golf
track for a little bit I've been married
for around eight years I certainly
wouldn't have any idea of what it's like
in the dating scene these days it's been
almost a decade and to be fair if I look
back my social awkwardness meant that I
could barely even string a decent
sentence together I fully relied on the
fact that I was a big okay looking dude
who liked to lifted a lot of Weights
back then my courting ritual of a
potential mate could have been compared
to a Silverback Gorilla beating his
chest or perhaps a dark Ahead version of
the American animated series of the late
90s Johnny Bravo hey baby I know what
you're thinking out of the statue get
off its pedestal well surprise I'm real
sugar nip what I'm trying to say is I
have absolutely no game but yesterday
all today's standards but these are
still bloody awkward to listen to even
by my standards however for consistency
I need to include these in the video
as requested for tilapia fillets
thank you
I cannot wait to try this famous ceviche
I thought you only made that for special
occasions or when you're trying to get
laid thanks Cindy
boss
sorry about her
I like her she's funny
and informative
so it's a special occasion
or do you just want to get laid
ah yeah I I don't know how to answer
that
I am sleeping with make account as a
special occasion
oh
okay
um I wow so
so
do you want to go in my office I kind of
live in there and there's a lock on the
door
well maybe you should take a shower
first you're cute but honey you stink
yeah right yeah sorry about that never
really feels like I can take a break
personal hygiene has been slipping for a
while now
bus talking or showering mister I need
to get back to the aquarium where people
are gonna suspect something's up
oh my god did you try the fish tacos
they're so freaking good
right if they lived with this we could
have overthrown a Black Tusk hindsight
I'm glad you made it out me too
I wish more of us made it no stop
we can't go there
we start crying we'll never stop
hey Manny
tell your girl thanks hey keep it down
what we're not public
[__] Mario have you tried the ceviche I
of course you gotta have some I'm good
you're missing out you pregnant or
something okay no more toilet wine for
you Manny can you handle him of course
I say
we are telling people oh [__] you're
gonna be your dad hey friend I really
like this girl can you just please shut
the [__] up
you knocked her up I hope you like it
okay I think it's time for bed I'll take
care of our boy go get your girl
we need to talk
oh no uh
did I do something wrong
oh you're not in trouble or anything
well at least I hope not
okay now you're scaring me
we're adults we're smart
college educated and all that are you
interviewing me for a job
no I just mean we aren't stupid and I'm
a scientist so I know how reproduction
works
okay now you've lost me
we've been having fun for a couple of
months
has it really been that long already
we've been having uninterrupted fun for
the last eight weeks
this may be my longest relationship be
serious
I am
I really like you Mari I like you too I
like you so much we've been having
unprotected sex for eight weeks with no
breaks
aren't you on birth control
where would I get birth control
are you pregnant
for now what do you mean for now
I mean
I've been pregnant before I've taken
care of it or my body has so
the odds of this baby making it to term
with Federal access to modern medicine
with a questionable diet and high stress
is not great
do you want to have a kid with me
well we've only known each other for a
couple of months
but
honestly I couldn't imagine a better
person to have a kid with
how can I help
uh I guess send your agents to read a
pharmacy for prenatal vitamins and find
a midwife
maybe we could build a barn for me to
give birth and I don't know we could die
tomorrow or it could be a hundred none
of those make sense
well then I guess I'll plan for a
hundred and be happy if we see tomorrow
has been located at the Manning National
Zoo
at the entrance agents are immediately
met with heavy Black Tusk resistance
while these aren't an issue for the ages
to dispatch they are now running against
the clock with hostiles aware of the
division being on site they need to move
fast before Mario's once again moved on
radio we understand it
was safe we need to secure the asset I'm
near the Aquarium I'll handle Mari
remember that said keep her stress low
handle The Intruders and start
evacuation procedures I'll keep her calm
and move to the Rendezvous copy bag
through the intercepted comms the black
task had been instructed to keep Mari
calm and comfortable but the agents
would also learn of her location
fighting through hordes of Black Tusk on
their way to the aquarium including some
warhounds the agents consider themselves
lucky not having similar Doggers that
were seen at the end of the last Manhunt
structure you'll have to contend with
predation and weather if you convert the
enclosure into a fish farm
are you sure there aren't any clocks in
there
this really doesn't feel very safe I
promise no Crocs skaters or apex
predators of any kind are in the
enclosures
pushing through the aquarium it appears
that Murray has been moved on
Mari was the director of the DC Aquarium
before she turned it into a fish farm
they probably want her to set up a
similar operation for the Black Tusk
food security is a powerful motivator
agent I've got eyes on Mari near the
Savannah
agents make their way over to the
you can't let the division destroy the
clinic we won't we should stay and fight
don't worry the Black Tusk will stop the
division thank you
get the patients out of here
they're running away from us but we're
trying to help them
I will let you take them
that Murray isn't the only pregnant
woman on site they seem to be using this
area of the zoo as a clinic it also
shows that the Personnel the agents have
been rescuing are only some of many
civilians that the black task have been
working with the propaganda machine is
going strong
you're not worried about predation
longer you keep the Dome closed you
shouldn't have to worry about where it's
doing the fish
the plants on top offer additional
protection
it's also nicer to work inside during a
storm and it's closer to the clinic
honestly you don't need all of this to
build a fish farm you're recommending we
look for another site for the operation
I'm recommending you use the
infrastructure of a zoo for a zoo We
need sustainable foods for the community
if we want people to come back and when
people are back they're going to be
bored and want to go on adventures
experience new things they'll want to go
to the zoo or the aquarium yes but
turning the aquarium into a fish farm we
already had a fish farm turning the
cross pet into a trout hole is very
different the exhibits weren't built for
people to grow food they were built to
keep the animals in
here is
wrong about all the Predators abandoning
your habitats you want a fish farm
convert a warehouse
as the agents move through the compound
they intercept quite a number of hostile
comms the black tasks are evacuating
quite a large number of personnel and
Murray has been moved along hastily
agent there's movement in the bamboo
forest near the panda enclosure I think
they're getting ready for another
extraction
Wally directs us to the next extraction
Point Murray could be on this one so the
agents waste no time in making it over
there
okay I think we should get you out of
here just in case something wrong
nothing you should worry about but I
prefer to get you somewhere more secure
too many access points we use extraction
send the Hilo meet us at the atrium
realizing that the agents are getting
close and that nothing seems to be
slowing them down the Black Tusk moved
Murray towards an extraction point
I'll let you know when it's safe to come
out
you'll be safe in there I'll let you
know when you can come out
someone is looking out for Murray agents
will need to worry about this later as
they engage in combat at the atrium with
one of the Black Tusk leaders that have
been looking after Murray
negative Atrium is compromised new
rendezvous at the arena copy that
eventually the leader would be taken
down and Murray could be heard of the
comms
Manny we sort of agreed he should sit
this one out that was probably a good
idea Torres is on her way I'll tell
Manny you're okay no please don't
wait until we're back in case anything
happens to us I don't want to get his
hopes up
how we've not quite done yet Murray was
relocated to the arena where another
black tuscalida is waiting to extract
her
don't shoot it's me I'm coming out
agent you can shoot a flare Taurus is on
her way
however when firing off the flare to
bring tourism the agents in Murray
weren't the only ones left on site
what you miss me or something thank you
agent
are you okay
did they hurt you hey I'm fine I'm fine
baby
so far so good
even got some prenatal vitamins
in a scam
yeah everything's normal
we're not out of the woods but their
doctors say she looks healthy
they took care of you you were safe with
them no
no I wasn't safe with them
that psycho was only good to me because
she knew she needed me alive to get what
she wants what does she want
for you to give her the White House
and to install her organization as
rightful military force
stand down and give her legitimacy what
else did you expect from a woman like
that maybe we should just give her what
she wants [__] that
I'm with Wally giving in to people like
that never ends well we can't do this
alone well we don't have to
where's Vic Sokolova has him
well then you get him back
he knows her operation he helped build
it
you want to take her down and you want
to protect your family get Vic
where's Kelso back in New York we need
to get sleep we have a big day tomorrow
thank you
that I just wanted to let you know the
asset is in place and awaits your orders
excellence
Murray very obviously doesn't buy into
what Natalia has been doing she is
certain that this whole thing was just a
part of Natalia's plan of manipulation a
plan to mislead and confuse many in the
team into just handing over the White
House
fear it's been working look at how many
reacted through this whole Manhunt in
the state he's now in he seems almost
defeated
but this is where Mari voices up and
tells him to snap out of it unlike many
she sees right through it Italia is
crazy she needs to be stopped and Wally
100 agrees with it
first things first they need to get
Vikram Malik back he has once again been
captured by the Black Tusk
as we've found out over this last season
he played a part in building her
operation he has the information they
need to take it down
I'm not doing that
yes you are
we should get some sleep
you should be working
I can't
can't we just take a break and be
grateful you're home and safe
yeah we can take a break
but tomorrow we get back to work
what does she want with you anyway
same thing you do
she wants a baby
no what is what is wrong with you she
wanted me to set up a fish farm at the
zoo
figured if I could repurpose the
exhibits of the aquarium to feed the
community
they could do something somewhere there
that's actually a pretty good idea
yeah it's not the worst idea
why the hell would they want to try to
maintain a fish farm at a zoo
I thought their whole thing was being
creepy infiltrating Raiders with too
much Tech and no morality
she's an heiress
she's probably tired of other caress the
soldiers stink
she's looking for something more stable
she's recruiting
trying to turn our people to her side
maybe she's ready for something bigger
if she controls the food supply and
offers protection and stability
she could turn the nation
or maybe the fish farm wasn't for her
I don't know I'm going to bed
so now that the season is wrapped up
there are a couple of big topics we need
to discuss
as Natalia actually turned good or as
Murray lost the plot what is the asset
Natalia was talking about and who was
the random unnamed person who helped
Mario out at the zoo and gave her the
division comps
let's start with what I sort of see as
the obvious one is Natalia in the Black
Tusk the good guys now
in my opinion absolutely not
I've been harping on about this since
the first minor Mission this season it
has all just screened as Natalya is
playing the same plan but trying a
different direction
I agree with what Murray said about
Natalia trying to get many to just hand
over the White House but I don't think
Mario Wally would ever let this happen
however I think this is only part of
what Natalia was trying to do with this
new approach I mean she was successful
with many he looks shattered like he
needs to take some sort of sabbatical or
something but look at what we found out
in their last mission
our Personnel that we've been bringing
back look to only be a fraction of who
Natalia has brought under her wing
there were a lot of people being
evacuated from the zoo while we were
there and from the sounds of it they
completely buy into what Natalia is
selling they were actually scared of the
division it would seem that the puppet
master has successfully begun
controlling the way the public see her
in the Black Tusk to be fair she should
have started doing this a long time ago
what many said there about whoever
controls the food and can provide
security will have the support of the
people isn't necessarily untrue but I
think on a much more basic level if
Natalia wanted to take control of DC or
the US she was always going to have a
much easier time if she had the general
public on her side
but she has a hell of a job ahead of her
looking at the Black Tusk from the
outside they don't exactly scream
friendly with their dark uniforms robot
attack dogs and other giant Tech they
leave all over the place as well as the
fact that they have mowed down an
unimaginable number of jtf since they've
first been in the city
maybe this is where the true sun's
coming
it did always seem strange that she
would bring them on board they didn't
really have a lot to offer her
perhaps they will be the ones that
handle the more civilian-facing missions
while the black tasks work on the more
undercover projects in the background so
the true Sons can gather all of the
negative press while Natalia continues
to boost the Black Tusk
anyway summing up with the Natalia is
now good no she is not her goal is still
the same as it has always been she is
simply just placing a bit more focus on
the black task's Public Image
so who is the asset Natalia was talking
about and what is Natalia going to do
with them
it could be easy to assume after this
last season of rescuing lesser-known
characters that perhaps one of them has
been turned by Natalia and is ready to
play out some sort of sabotage on many
or the castle sediment
but I don't think this is the case
all of them have very close
relationships with many before they were
captured and none of their personalities
seem like the type to do this obviously
we could be surprised but it still
doesn't feel right to me instead I
believe the asset to be something else
in the past we've heard Natalia use
similar language during the burden
Shafer main hunt and what they were
referring to as the asset then was a
hunter
so I'm going to say that this is what
she's put in place
but to do what
well I think this is where my last
question comes in who was the person
behind the Voice who helped keep Mario
safe during her rescue
take this put it in your ear I'll let
you know when it's safe to come out
you'll be safe in there I'll let you
know when you can come out
when I first heard the voice like most I
assume I noticed there wasn't a name
attached to the subtitles
my mind went straight to things like
maybe it was a jtf officer who had
infiltrated the compound who was getting
ready to extract her once we had dealt
with the last of the hostiles
or maybe it was a Defector within the
Black Tusk ranks who had managed to get
hold of the division comms base
but then we will get to the end of the
mission and someone familiar that we've
seen once before would show himself
now I'll admit it the voice being a
hunter or more specifically the
recruiter didn't fit for me
but the more time I spent trying to
prove this wrong the more likely it
ended up becoming
I went back through all of my mind maps
Venn diagrams and whiteboards that I've
used to piece all the stories together
over the years across the different
media types and games I looked through
all the past and current characters to
try and make sense of it and who could
have stepped in at the last minute there
but I kept coming up blank
however when I stood back and actually
assessed the potential significance of
those couple of lines along with
Natalia's mention of the asset the scene
showing the recruiter and the fact that
a lot of the comms this season coming
out of The Descent game mode have been
bringing a lot of light to the role of
the hunters it's hard not to come to the
conclusion that this was the voice of
the recruiter
but then why would he help marry
I mean we all love the hunters but when
it comes to agents versus Hunters
they're the bad guys right
I don't think this is a situation where
the voice actor maybe didn't portray the
character in the correct way
because I regularly chat to the overlord
of all that is the division law and she
is most certainly not someone who would
settle for a mediocre attempt at voicing
one of her creations
so if there was the recruiter it kind of
sounded like a decent guy not the bad
guy you would expect
well like everything in this game I
think there's a lot more to it
based on the Intel we're receiving from
The Descent coms it's looking very
likely that one of the first
speculations around what we thought the
hunters were may actually be pretty
close
I put out a video my first speculation
video actually five years ago called who
are the hunters
to date this is still the most popular
video I've ever released which is sad
because it was actually demonetized
almost immediately by Ubisoft because I
didn't like some of the survival footage
I used apparently but we won't talk
about that right now basically the most
favored speculation I could talk to at
the time was that the hunters were the
third wave
now I don't think that they're the third
wave but I believe their position
through this whole thing is very similar
to what we were talking about way back
then they were put in place as sort of a
division agent control system
I say division agent rather than rogue
agent because there seems to be a very
blurry line between these two things
these days so for the purpose of this
video Let's just Round Up Rogues and
division agents as the same thing and
Hunters are a suppression system put in
place to control them if needed
this isn't meant to be an agent versus
Hunter video because I feel the answer
to that is pretty clear
if pitted against each other one-on-one
not the player character but an average
division agent versus a hunter the agent
wouldn't stand a chance
this isn't because the shd agent is
worse than the hunter they just have
very different functions
agents are there to save what remains
work closely with those in society to
help rebuild while fighting back against
any hostile uprisings they may encounter
Hunters they're specialized in doing
exactly what their name suggests hunt
down a Target and eliminate
I think of the hunters as being like a
ghost recon ghost no I'm not saying that
Ghost Recon is the same universe as the
division that has been confirmed as
false many times I'm just using them as
an example
Hunters are super Black Ops except while
ghosts are still formidable on their own
they're most effective in a small Squad
we're Hunters work solo even agents
while deployed in cells are perfectly
capable working alone unless they're
running raids or recursions of the team
basically the hunters are far more
highly trained combat units than the
agents but their purpose is much
narrower
rather than being trained the hunters
are recruited it's the recruiter
think before the outbreak the hunters
were recruited from various branches of
Special Forces so these guys are
American troops super deadly troops but
still people fighting for their country
why do I think this matters
while Calvin McManus isn't exactly a
good guy it would seem and the hunters
do report directly to him they aren't
just Mindless killing machines I don't
think they want to see you as civilians
being killed on mass by the Black Tusk
division agents or anyone else stuck in
this conflict and I think there is the
potential there that the recruiter is
going a little off Mission well at least
a little bit off kelvin's mission
let's assume for a second there that the
Hunter's whole mission that they have
been given was to eliminate division
agents who have gone off mission
these things currently are it isn't
really clear who is and isn't on Mission
so perhaps the hunters or at least their
leader the recruiter is feeling a little
conflicted in the direction everything
is headed
also given that they're using at least
one of the three AI systems it's
possible they have hacked into it and
seen everything that's been going on
like Aaron Kina did
maybe the recruiter is looking for
someone on the other side of this war to
converse with about this whole thing
someone he sees as an equal with a
similar moral compass someone who can
help bring balance to the situation and
this is why he's been watching us for so
long now he's been assessing whether we
could be trusted
remember Calvin and Natalia wouldn't
exactly be able to recognize us if we
were recruited as we all know Hunters
don't talk and their identity is hidden
by a mask we might not even be the first
division agent that has been recruited
into the hunter ranks
I could probably just keep pretling on
about this including a number of
directions the story could take but for
this video I think this is enough now I
want to revisit this soon though now
that I've managed to put all the crazy
stuff in my head down his words on a
screen I've freed up some space to keep
mailing this over so I'll keep you
updated with anything that could be
interesting
otherwise what do you think this all
means do you have a different take on
who the asset is or who could be behind
the voice let us all know in the
comments
this season has been a big one for the
story and it's showing in the length of
my videos even with some of the super
minor targets the wrap-up compilation
video for the season is going to be
ridiculously long anyway thank you very
much for your patience with waiting for
this video I hope it was worth the wait
thanks again for all the support and
extremist malice extreme remedia
oh